bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france vous l'avez
entendu emmanuel mâcon est ce que vous
le croyez sincère je pense qu'il n'a pas
vraiment le choix que d'admettre
qu'effectivement il ya eu une erreur qui
a été fait et la mise en place de cette
taxe mais elle est représentative d'un
mécanisme de mise en place de mesures
dites écologiques ne tiennent absolument
pas compte de la dimension sociale juste
sur cette déclaration a accordé à la
chaîne ainsi billet ce qu'on ne croit
sincère ou pas il y avait du mouvement
d'aidé gilet jaune d'abord à ce que vous
croyez que s'était adressé au gilet
jaune
et puis est-ce que ça pour relancer le
mouvement dans la rue ça c'est qu'on
peut répondre je pense qu'il ya pas que
le sujet de la taxe carbone et des
inégalités sociales liées à la fiscalité
en france qui met les gens globalement
en colère 1 il ya le sujet des salaires
jugés des retraites
il ya pas mal de sujets les
mobilisations qui avait été enclenchée
avant le début de la crise sanitaire et
7 passes simplement ce sujet là je pense
qu'ils pourraient relancer uniquement la
mobilisation en revanche je pense pas
qu'il ya de vrai volonté du gouvernement
d'aller plus en avant dans cette
transition écologique de manière juste
j'entends d'une part parce que cette
taxe carbone lorsque personnellement
j'ai lancé cette pétition était
accompagné de dix propositions donc la
première était de cesser la hausse de
l'augmentation des taxes et c'est ce qui
a été fait qu 6 décembre où elle a été
la valeur carbone avaient été gelés mais
en l'occurrence y avait aussi le sujet
de supprimer la tva sur la taxe ça c'est
inadmissible qu'on sera doublement taxés
et puis d'autres mesures qui justement
visé l'accompagnement donc le fait de
propos de proposer aux personnes qui
n'avaient pas les meubles et la
possibilité de prendre un autre moyen
devait de se déplacer que le véhicule
bengale puisse le faire par un train par
quart et c est de pouvoir financer des
carburants des projets de carburants
propres
or quand on a été à la rencontre de
françois de rugy fin novembre 2018 et le
gouvernement précisé via sa voix que ce
n'était pas du tout prévu qu'ils
financent des projets de carburant
propre en prison est ce que vraiment ils
ont envie d'aller vers la transition
écologique et est ce qu'ils ont vraiment
envie d'accompagner la population moi
j'ai rien vu depuis deux ans qui le
montrait est le dernier exemple en date
comme quoi ils ne tiennent pas compte de
ces mesures plus justes c'est le projet
qui a été proposée par la france en
titane pour le climat qui proposait de
taxer
l'aérien pour les trajets plus de quatre
heures qui proposait de de réduire la
taxe sur les sur les transports en
commun donc quelques aces qui font
concrètement pour nous accompagner au
delà taxe est constamment non je vous
posais la question justement par rapport
à cette fameuse taxe sur les carburants
la déclaration de daimiel macron parce
que cette taxe sur les carburants c'est
ce qui a lancé le mouvement des gilets
jaunes donc ça me renvoie au tout début
du mouvement
et est ce que vous pensez que ben
justement vis-à-vis de l'opinion
publique ça vous donne raison
aujourd'hui un rouge
en tout cas oui je vous dirais je pense
que ça s'est vérifié effectivement ce
que j'avais indiqués dans la pétition
comme quoi elle été injustement
articuler cette taxe s'activant taper
toujours sur les ménages lorsqu'il y
avait une volonté d'aller chercher des
sous mais en l'occurrence une partie de
ses sauts a été détourné pour aller la
remercie ses yeux et il est un avantage
fiscal perçu aux entreprises donc du
coup oui je pense que ça va donner
raison ce a donné raison
un million de personnes un peu plus qui
ont signé cette pétition et qui n'ont
toujours pas eu de réponse a pas
d'accompagnement et pas de l'alternative
5 cette crise sanitaire elle a mis entre
parenthèses un peu le lait la grogne
sociale
les manifestations les samedis de
manifestations de dd gilet jaune
on espère sortir de cette crise
notamment avec la vaccination une fois
que tous les français seront vaccinés
puis on va approcher d'une échéance très
important que la présidentielle est ce
qu on pourra revoir peut-être les gilets
jaunes dans la rue cette fois avec un un
combat précis c'est à dire à lutter
contre un éventuel second mandat
d'emmanuel vaqueront je peux pas parler
au nom des idéaux c'est comme vous savez
ces manuscrits leur proprement parler à
mes lettres votre sentiment à vous votre
opinion
comment sortir mon sentiment à moi c'est
que oui on devrait pouvoir mobiliser
davantage pour qu on se retrouve pas
encore en 2022 avec le sketch plein et
qu'en l'occurrence on a une forte
demande de transformation des
institutions et transformations
politiques profondes qui est réclamée
par le mouvement des jeunes en
l'occurrence dès le départ et qui
d'autre ou mouvement et que le
gouvernement actuel veut pas entendre
donc oui j'espère qu'il y aura de fortes
mobilisations
et que on se retrouvera pas conscient
avec les mêmes personnages sa gauche par
exemple on cherche une alternative
notamment autour des peut-être des
écologistes vous pensez que la question
justement des enjeux environnementaux ça
va être une l'un des fondamentaux à
venir pour cette campagne présidentielle
avec évidemment les enjeux de santé
oui je pense je pense effectivement que
la question de l'urgence climatique est
déjà entendue et revendiquée depuis un
certain nombre de temps et avec par des
générations de plus en plus jeunes
d'ailleurs ce qu'on a mis mouvement des
étudiants qui se font de plus en plus
intense et en paca l'échelle française
mais en plus de ça on a le sujet des
violences environnementale aussi qui
causent des dégâts sur l'environnement
et sur nos en gardant de vie et sur
notre santé marie cochet et d'amplis le
sujet de la santé liés à la crise
sanitaire et le sujet de la santé
fragilisée par les violences
environnementale dont on ne peut pas
qu'on ne peut pas en fait aller en
justice pour se défendre quand on est
touché par ces violences urbaines au
mental parce que le gouvernement ne veut
pas reconnaître le crime dans
l'environnement talk et l'écocide qui a
été proposé par la province ancien parc
pour climat mais dont ils ont refusé de
légiférer dessus donc du coup oui je
pense que ce sera un très gros enjeu
pour le l'approché le prochain mandat
merci à vous presser réalise au ski je
rappelle que vous êtes l'une des
initiatrices et figure du mouvement des
gilets jaunes